huge wildfires in southern turkey have
killed at least
four people and injured hundreds more
emergency crews are battling
more than 60 separate blazes authorities
have told tourists to leave
several popular beach resorts officials
say arsonists
may have started the fires
these men wanted to help the
hard-pressed firefighters
they brought warm meals for the
emergency workers
but then found themselves trapped
despite what they called hellish
conditions they managed to drive to
safety
like them thousands of people in
southern turkey are in danger
the fire came suddenly and turned
everything to ashes
we barely got out alive the children
went one way we went the other
it's absolutely devastating
amidst the chaos some even had to
extinguish the flames
themselves
but when i got here it was engulfed in
flames
in popular resorts along the coast
tourists had to flee from their hotels
many were ferried to safety
satellite data shows these are the
hottest wildfires
ever seen in turkey with some areas
sizzling at almost 50 degrees celsius
by now we were hoping to contain some of
the fires
we can cautiously say things are
improving but we cannot say they are
under control
investigators are looking into whether
the first fires
were started by arsonists however they
began
the authorities are now dealing with a
full-scale
disaster
dw correspondent dorian jones joins us
now from istanbul with
more dorian what can you tell us about
the situation
right now with the fires
well the firefighters are already
battling in inferno conditions with
these fires being whipped up by these
strong
powerful dry winds which continue to
fire the fires which
continue to create a trail of death and
destruction
but having said that the turkish
authorities have said that they have
managed to bring
50 out of the over 70 fires under
control
but we are now getting reports that
another major fire has broken out
uh close to fetia and an important sea
resort
uh and that's why our evacuation orders
have been started to be issued to many
villages in the
in the region and school dormitories
have now been opened up
for shelter and with the forecasts uh
predicting whether to write even
higher temperatures the firefighters
know they're in for a very long fight
well we also know that many of these
wildfires have struck very close to some
of turkey's tourist hot spots
dorian how bad of an impact is this
having on turkey's
tourist industry which is very important
well absolutely and the tourism industry
has been recovering from the pandemic
epidemic which saw income fall last year
by over
70 percent there was a hope that this
year could be a turning point
but these fires have dealt a hammer blow
to this now authorities have been saying
that the major resorts are safe which
are popular with not only turks but
people from all across europe but now
they have started to issue warnings
for tourists to leave some resorts and
even before those warnings a number of
hotels had to be evacuated in one case
dramatically
people were evacuated by sea because the
only road to that hotel
had been cut off now that uh this latest
uh epic and latest uh
fires will continue to deal more woe to
the hotel owners in the region
and for sure a terrifying situation for
these
tourists and also the residents in the
area now um
during also we're hearing from
authorities who say they suspect that
arsonists may have started the fires
is there evidence to support these
claims
well what you have to understand is that
this region before these fires broke out
have been experiencing record high
temperatures along with these strong dry
winds which had turned much of the
region into a tinderbox
and so the the fact of fires was not
unexpected but authorities say that
it's because several of these fires
started in quick succession has led to
them to suspect possible foul play
and top suspect is his kurdish
separatist group the pkk
which is fighting the turkish state for
decades and has in the past
warned that it would target turkey's
tourism area but having said that
turkey's claim turkish government claims
of arsene cometh is facing mounting
criticism the fact that turkey only has
three firefighting planes for a vast
country
the government has now taken up office
of help from ukraine russia
and azerbaijan but still the criticism
is growing over its handling of this
firefighting crisis
dw's dorian jones reporting from
istanbul thanks so much for bringing us
up to date